[Music]
resident wait who is that they and the
tip you can ask the question and then
ask another question without my answer
Omarosa Manigault Neumann is put in the
hot seat in a live Today Show interview
and things heat up quickly when
discussing her tenure working for
President Trump you think the president
lies often
oh absolutely effect there how long were
known that there was a report that said
that he lied almost 4000 lies in the
last have you known that his he is a
liar as you say well absolutely why
don't you work for him Savannah's slow
down I'm gonna ask your question don't
worry I'm here I've got all the time
no but I'm you don't have to ask ten
questions in one second it's okay first
of all he is known to be an entertainer
to exaggerate but I never expected him
to lie to the country after Omarosa
accused Trump of lying about whether he
knew she was being fired from her
position as his former director of
communications for the office of public
liaison the 44 year old claims she heard
an alleged tape of the POTUS using the
n-word during his apprentice days but
when Omarosa is put on the spot about it
things get tense you actually heard it
so let's get let's go watch how long is
how long is this tape there multiple
tapes let's establish that and when you
read my book tomorrow which is available
tomorrow on hinge you'll see that there
are three different sources who
cooperate the different things that you
say you have since the book I have
listened put that tape it's about three
minutes is it audio or video because
he's honest to be camera out take audio
okay and what is the context but how do
I allow you this like most Americans to
read the book but this isn't about no no
but the talk about the inner tape is
throughout the book I've heard they have
you read the book yes but have you okay
having I have I entered that question
Savannah so what's the next question yes
I was curious the context in which you
alleged the president you see you were
about some African Americans in the
production okay during the course of the
apprentice
[Music]